def curry in the Warriors or Kobe what's
the bigger story in your mind well first
of all uh thanks for having me on really
appreciate it I appreciate little sugar
mags coming in I appreciate the
compliment on so let me take you behind
scenes of NBA TV last night uh working
with producer Matt Cain and and Dennis
Scott Vinny Del Negro man we have a good
time last night I've been there 14 years
that is the hottest most electric most
intense most unbelievable night I've
ever been a part of and I've been a part
of a lot of them I've been covering
final since two thousand four uh that's
as good as its ever gotten for me um so
initially our rundown you know we had 73
and nine that's pursuit of 400 freeze
leading off it was alone in the eighth
lock and then uh and then last night
happens and Kobe steals the show we
opened the show last night with Kobe on
the back after da block was the Warriors
um I mean I if Kobe scores 50 do we
flip-flop da block I don't know Kobe
score 60 forced our hand yes Kobe in his
final game stole the show from the 73
and I Warriors what the hell Rick it's
unbelievable I mean and really
everywhere you go they're talking more
about Kobe yeah you see their highlights
first you see what Kobe did first it was
truly magical and I think part of that
Rick might have been the Warriors fault
for not making that game competitive you
know I mean that was a foregone
conclusion let's start with Kobe then
does the 50 shots make any difference to
you Rick whatsoever because I know I've
seen on Twitter some people saying yeah
but he took 50 shots they're haters on
that's just that plain and simple
they're haters Byron Scott said before
the game we're gonna try to get a ball
every time down the court we said it
that was the coaches game plan to the
game every player on the team one defeat
Kobe and it's the guy is he's fit on my
all-time list okay third all-time in
scoring five rings a lot of people claim
him is the greatest of all time I think
those people are Millennials I think
they're out of their minds
they need to watch some more old school
basketball he's one of the all-time
all-time greats but he's not be great I
think that's a coin flip that lands on
Jordan for me between Kareem
abdul-jabbar Michael Jordan but those
are haters anybody saying odd took in 50
shots to get 60 points the guys played
20 years he's 37 he's in the last three
years overcome a ruptured achilles a
broken knee and a ruptured labrum in his
right shoulder by the way that's a
shooting shoulder so I'm not listening
to that at all those are just haters
we're talking with Rick camel does a
really nice job for NBA TV and Turner
Sports can you think Rick of a better
final performance for an NBA player I
don't know if I can think of a better
final performance by anybody in any
sport you know Peyton Manning just got
the chip on his way out but Peyton
Manning was along for the ride he
admitted it we watch the games we all
sought and this is not a championship
this is the worst season in Lakers
history but to me the previous 81 games
are all washed away with what we saw
last night nobody thought the Lakers
were going to be good they were I mean
essentially it was a very very quiet
tank and I'm not you know accusing them
of anything but they weren't going out
there a heavy metal they were trying to
win because if the lakers are finished
you know for through 14 in the lottery
the pic goes to Philadelphia if the one
two or three two picks days in LA so you
guys tell me anyway I just think that
it's it's by far the best closing game
in NBA history John Havlicek had the
previous arm yeah all-time NBA high of
29 in a final career game and Kobe more
than doubled that up Rick I felt like
especially at the end I felt like the
Jazz were playing co be pretty tough I
felt like they were contested shots and
I felt like the fact that he finished
with such a flourish and needed to do
that to win really adds to the legacy I
mean people that just hear Kobe had 16
the lakers won it doesn't do it justice
in my mind if you didn't actually watch
and see how it went down would you agree
I totally agree in itself one of the
marquee matchups on NBA TV today I think
uh Kobe's game is at one
and the Dubs game is at three Eastern
don't it might be noon into but check
your listings for NBA TV if you want to
watch the Kobe game again because
because we're airing it again this
afternoon if you watched it your jaw
dropped me and Dennis cotton Vinny Del
Negro last night were like children were
like oh my god I can't believe he hit up
10 my god and everybody in the studio
was was insane it was absolute insanity
look they tried Sheldon back on and they
tried gordon hayward on they tried trey
lyles on him to put a longer dude on him
he just kept making shot on it was
vintage Kobe I mean he you know a few
dribbles into that sort of elbow area to
get that shot off like game-winner hit
against Phoenix he was in step back
threes on it was just awesome and
absolutely awesome and Kobe Bryant at
the podium last night was he had a I
can't believe I just did that tone to
him and I thought it was really cool
talk with Rick Kamla NBA TV let's
transition Rick to the Warriors I guess
I want to start with steph curry and the
three-point record I mean I can't think
of any other guy in any other sport
maybe Jerry Rice but two obliterator
record like that try to put that in some
perspective for me is there any
comparison you can make ya a Barry Bonds
home run record I think it's up there
with look Steph last year set the record
at 286 get 402 this year and he did not
play in the fourth quarter of 18 or 19
games because they were such blow up to
deal with those numbers for a minute
Stephan curry last night uh it was his
16th game this year with eight or more
threes anybody and I don't care if
you're talking about an old school hall
of fame basketball player uh and and I
certainly don't know more about
basketball than those brilliant people
but I just I think if you're holding on
to step is not the best shooter of all
time you're kind of in the haters own I
think you're sipping on the haterade a
little bit nobody has made 303 he just
made 400 his percentage on fries from 30
or more feet this year nineteen of 40
okay BRR
is awesome as he was couldn't do that
Kevin Durant who is arguably you know in
the top four three shooters in our game
right now can't do that nobody can do
that only Stephan curry can do that Rick
what do guys like Dennis Scott and Vinny
Del Negro who you're with all the time
where do they stand on how the warriors
would have done back in the day I mean
those are a couple old heads those guys
were in the NBA back when I was watching
where do they stand it seems like you
talk about haters seemed like a lot of
those guys that play in the eighties in
the 90s hate on the Warriors all the
time well those two guys in particular
do not but but I I totally agree with
what you're saying you're a lot of the
you know the guys the plane eighties
nineties even the 70 saying you know by
their just a jump shooting team and all
this kind of stuff and I wonder if those
old cats are actually watching all of
these games because the action that
Steve Kerr wants the way Golden State
plays defense they get pain points there
are fast-breaking swashbuckling you know
Showtime in the new millennium team uh I
don't think some of the old heads are
watching it up these Warriors because if
they were watching them they would just
be like like well i watch the Warriors
and I'm just like stop it just stop it
it's to that point you're just like come
on i mean like buddy hield in the NCAA
tournament you know in that oregon game
it's like to stop it you're you're too
good I that's what the Warriors are
right now but a lot of people don't want
to recognize that again they're sipping
on haterade Rick what about in moving
forward into the playoffs now the
Warriors can anybody beat them if sue if
so who and hell I don't think anybody's
going to get them this year san antonio
home court advantage I might pick the
Spurs but San Antonio proved they can't
hang with GSW at Oracle Arena and you
know two losses there this year one
Boston 12 minutes ohta odd during a
spell or I thought Golden State was
really physically and mentally fatigued
and they won't be in the playoffs right
now I do think warriors first will be
the Western finals I do think it's going
seven but i think the Warriors are going
to win and they I think we'll play
Cleveland in the NBA Finals and probably
beat them and fix wow so you think it's
going 7 with San Antonio and six with
Cleveland all right so good you it won't
they won't waltz through the playoff you
think it will be very competitive series
I like it well I think they might walk
on
till then haha you know I think I think
uh Houston might get a game uh might I
think the the Clippers who match up well
with Golden State there's a hatred
rivalry there if that's a second-round
series i can't wait Adi Clippers might
get two games off of them i'll give the
Clippers that credit the Clippers ain't
beat them I'll tell you that Rick really
appreciate the time and getting your
thoughts on what was a historic night in
the Association last night thanks Rick
anytime then call me all right there is
Rick Kamla from NBA TV the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience